some have said this is the most
controversial Gray's Anatomy episode I
think it's time for me to chime in let's
get started I know Denny's cardiac
parameters I know how his lvad works
better than any other intern I also know
his meds better I know the frequency the
dosage the quantity and his physical
limitations that's actually a really
important factor in the success of any
medical treatment if your medical team
is well versed on your chart the chance
of a mistake occurring drops down
significantly and by the way patients
need to take some initiative here on
their own to know what medications
they're taking to be interested ask
questions advocate for themselves if not
themselves their family members advocate
for them because I can't even begin to
say how many of my patients come in
taking 10 different medications not
knowing what they're for what their
dosages are and that's a mistake waiting
to happen I have some names for you oh
this is our guy from Walking Dead and um
he looks like Lewis Espino from the
channel by the way does he not oh he was
in Magic City one of my favorite
canceled TV shows you're getting a heart
Danny
I don't mean to be dramatic at all but
I'm gonna need you to repeat that he
looks and sounds exactly like hispina
it's crazy what's the weirdest reaction
you had from a patient in doing a
prostate exam I've had strange sounds I
had one guy almost break my finger off
you
are getting hurt I'll give you more
what the hell happened to my daughter he
went into v-fib oh no give me the palace
grab take over compressions okay please
please don't shock the Flatline patient
he's a stock I don't get it he's Ace of
solid because his heart is no longer
having any electrical activity and you
trying to restart his heart by Shocking
is not how it works you give the
epinephrine if not it fails it fails
just because your donor's heart died
doesn't mean I have to give you mine is
your patient higher on the transplant
list I have no idea the way that they
decide is based on proximity matching
obviously and matching includes HLA
typing blood typing cross-typing and
then one of the most important things
for a heart is actually the size and
shape of the recipient's chest cavity so
imagine you have a very small person
getting a very big heart that heart may
not be able to beat properly and
therefore it's not a good match as of
this morning Dr Hans patient was 22
hundredths of a point ahead that's
basically a tie the point ahead based on
Whose scoring system I know like for
liver transplants to put people on a
list there's actually scores that we use
called meld scores I forgot what the
other one is called for heart transplant
I wasn't even aware there was a score
and there were two donors is he our
guy's hard flat line now he's trying to
get the other guys there's a list yes
then the higher guy gets the heart
Denny's getting worse by the second
Saturday now in the 70s and dropping is
he I'm not
I understand advocating for ones you
care about but you can't lie this is
like the equivalent of killing someone
else did she put him on a Nitro trip
um yes yes of course she could be
putting paddles directly on his heart
he's still not getting this thing the
amount of animosity in this hospital is
bewildering to me the fact that one
doctor is like I don't care if you're
patient on the death but you ain't get
my heart and then the other person is
just making it up and acting like their
patient's dying when they're absolutely
not what is happening Dr Han what if Dr
Berg wants to run Labs do an echo and a
BNP to fully ascertain the status of his
patient will allow it that'll take an
hour that's going to take longer than an
hour by the way especially in most busy
Hospital Systems getting an echo means
getting attacked then getting a
cardiologist to read it like that's just
not gonna happen stat he'll get the next
heart is no he needs to get this heart
he'll probably get a heart at some point
but as long as Denny's doing well on the
lvad and there's someone ahead of him on
the transplant list he's not going to
get this hard they're almost saying it
and stuff like honeybee have to follow
the rules no no this is the right thing
to do rules or not the person who is in
Act of danger deserves the heart not the
person you want to go on the date
deserves the heart you're right okay
thank you if she starts poisoning him
I'm gonna lose my mind in order for you
to get the heart you would have to get
worse much worse and you would have to
do it very quickly well I don't see that
happening you see that happening I am
going to make it happen I had Gray's
Anatomy on my list I don't remember
where it was but I just demoted it I
retroactively I'm going to go back into
that video and demote Gray's Anatomy
after seeing me like this Catherine
Heigl deserves to be like the evil
version of House MD that doesn't try and
secretly make their patients better by
being unethical but just secretly wants
to kill her patients by being unethical
don't worry
you're not gonna die I will be here the
whole time oh my gosh
I didn't expect this all right this is
wrong you've waited a year and a half to
get this thing who knows when the next
one is going to come along is this how
she gets kicked off the show please
okay I'll do it you know like when you a
conversation goes too far and you have
to like walk it back I'm gonna walk this
back you have two patients that need a
heart there's only one heart available
one patient is actually sick but the
other patient who's okay and stable
waiting for a heart is in love and
because they're in love and their
manipulative doctor girlfriend or person
whoever they are in this relationship
wants the heart's so bad that they're
actually going to screw over the person
who's dying in order to get the heart
and Lobby for the heart to come to their
lover holy okay after I do this I
might have to shock you a few times do
what Izzy
um I feel like we should stay stuff
does anybody want to say stuff a person
is actively about to be murdered and
this other resident George has no qualms
about this
unplug it why are you
you could law breaker man all I have to
do is confirm that his condition is
worse and then Burke and call you knows
and he'll move up on the list and he
will get his heart she's gone insane
right it's not just me he's been shot
what
this is a comedy
oh
this is I don't know if the writers
deserve a raise or someone should take
away their Adderall because this is a
problem
this is bad this is bad and serious and
it gets a lot of rules it's not fun for
me I don't want to play what if you
remain well I wouldn't have fallen in
love with a patient do you fell in love
with an attention what sort of bear
what's the point the point is we can't
help but we fall in love with okay I
think this is a point that I have to say
this doesn't happen in hospitals this is
the equivalent of saying that like that
crazy story that happened on Netflix
with the murdering nurse that happens
everywhere no no no it doesn't happen
everywhere how's this heart looking just
laugh ventricle is shot and he's barely
pushing blood out when a heart starts
having a very low ejection fraction that
puts you into a risk for developing
arrhythmias in the heart potentially
fatal ones because then you're not able
to adequately supply the heart with the
blood that it needs to function and keep
beating because remember the heart's job
is not just to pump blood to the body
but also to itself and actually in
patients who fall below a certain
ejection fraction threshold they
actually get something known as an
implantable defibrillator that if their
heart starts failing so bad that it
stops or goes into an abnormal Rhythm it
actually shocks them back I love him
you don't even know him I do know him
you've never even seen him outside the
four walls of this Hospital you don't
know him I know him do you know who
should be most afraid of her the dude
because if she's willing to kill you for
love do you know what she's gonna do if
you try and break up with her
there's possibility here and and given
the choice of running or staying you
should
a sane person a person who values her
career and everything she's worked for
how about the other person's heart how
about Humanity
he's hypoxic he doesn't know what he's
saying he said marry me right he did
any wake up wait stop dying and tell me
you want to marry me ah he's Flatline no
no he's not Flatline there's movement in
his Hearts okay um let's shock him uh
charge the people later they don't even
know what Rhythm Is it is it shockable
is it not talkable but let's shock them
we need that medicine one medicine I'll
know it when I see it I think the one
that stops the heart
is keep my heart beating no no it only
stopped your heart for six seconds
adenosine is a medication that we use to
break supraventricular tachycardia which
is the SVT that they just mentioned and
basically it's a pretty scary medication
to give because when you give it it
actually completely stops the heart and
allows the heart to restart and
sometimes it could break it there's also
some unique things that we do to try and
trigger a Breaking of an SVT like
dunking a patient's head in cold water
like I'm not even joking or having them
try and bear down and do Val Salva
Maneuvers kind of interesting okay
pending Doom does happen with adenosine
can't see flat lines for a few seconds
and then it should come back
fools try to have a good explanation for
this people in medical school and
residency would throw you under the bus
because you came four minutes late to
lecture here their residents are so
tight-knit that they'll help prevent the
murder to help out a romance in the
hospital he's gonna get the heart right
you're gonna sign the charts and talk to
the transplant coordinator
okay the labs I'm gonna guess that his
BNP is significantly elevated on his
Echo he has a worsening ejection
fraction and if they did a chest x-ray
they're going to see significant
pulmonary edema see his BUN and
creatinine are increasing okay B1
creating because these kidneys are
failing he clearly has pulmonary edema
he deserves to move up to one a status
on the transplant list okay by the way
bun creatinine is not what decides
pulmonary edema pulmonary edema is
decided by a chest x-ray so this is
complete horse poop oh and by the way I
keep saying BNP but I'm not defining it
BNP is brain naturic peptide but it's a
marker that is released uh when there is
significant strain on the heart and a
lot of times it is reflective of when a
heart is failing signaling that there's
worsening of congestive heart failure
look at that thing
the left ventricle is excessively
dilated when we talk about congestive
heart failure a lot of times we talk
about an enlarged left ventricle the
left ventricle is the part of the heart
that actually sends blood to the rest of
the body so when that part of the heart
can get actually too big it hypertrophes
it doesn't fill and relax as well in
order to fill with blood and then send
blood to the rest of the body including
the heart so there's two types of
dysfunctions when it comes to heart
failure systolic heart failure when the
heart can't pump as well and in
diastolic heart failure where the heart
can't relax as well both are big
problems slightly for different reasons
but the treatments medication wise
change depending on whether it's
systolic or diastolic heart failure
you look
God you look amazing is it bad that I
secretly want him to break up with her
right now and then she goes into cardiac
arrest from stress-induced
cardiomyopathy like tacosobo and then he
has to do CPR while the rest of the
rescue people arrive that would be
really fun
he's flatlining why is no one being
notified of this
why is it the monitoring alerting
anybody if he just had a heart
transplant he's in the Cardiac Care Unit
at the very least he's hooked up to
Telemetry and someone is being notified
of that I think it was a stroke he was
prone to blood clots a clot could have
formed on a sutures travel to his brain
it only takes it could have been a lot
of other things but you know guessing in
A Moment Like This is really appropriate
because clearly you have zero medical
ethics speaking of scams here are some
Tick Tock scams of when they're trying
to get you to purchase products that are
absolute BS click here to check that out
and as always stay happy and healthy and
don't become a criminal and cut people's
hell that wires
[Music]